وفي سياق ردود الفعل الفلسطينيه عما اضراب
عام مدينه نابلس حدادا واحتجاجا على
العمليه الاسرائيليه وقالت حركه الجهاد
الاسلاميه ان اعدام شهداء الثلاثه جريمه
بشعه جديده تسجل في سجل الاحتلال
واضافت الحركه ان حكومه الاحتلال تعلن
الحرب الشامله على الفلسطينيين ما يستوجب
الرد عليها بكل الطرق والوسائل الجبهه
الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين قالت ان المجزره
الجديده لم تضعف اراده المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ونجماهير الشعب الفلسطيني
بتشكيلاته المقاومه كافه ستجعل الاحتلال
يدفع ثمن جرائمه اما حركه فتح فرات عمليه
الاغتيال في نابلس تاتي في سياق الحرب
المفتوحه التي تمارسها حكومه اسرائيل
لارهاب شباب الفلسطيني
من نابلس مراسل الجزيره سمير ابو شمالي
سمير اذا عرين الاسود تنعاش شهدائها
الثلاثه ماذا في التفاصيل
نعم في البدايه نحن الان نتواجد عند مفترق
الشهداء في قلب او مركز مدينه
نابلس حيث تظهر الصوره هناك حاله من
الحداد العام تشهدها المدينه يتخلل هذه
الحاله اضراب تجاريه جزئيه وذلك حدادا على
ارواح الشهداء الثلاثه الذين سقطوا برصاص
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هذا او فجر هذا
اليوم مجموعات عريض الاسود في مدينه نابلس
صدرت قبل قليل بيانا نعت فيه
الشهداء الثلاثه وايضا قالت بان هؤلاء هم
من مقاتلين الذين كانوا قد كانوا يحاولون
نصب كمين لاحدى الفرق التابعه لجيش
الاحتلال وتحديدا لوحده جولاني عند حاجز
سره العسكري ولكن تبين لها بان هناك كمين
اخر نصب لهذه المجموعه المسلحه وكان ودار
الاشتباك المسلح بالمسافه الصفر مع جنود
الاحتلال الذين كانوا يتحصلون
وينصبون كمينا في احدى البنايات قيد
الانشاء القريبه من حاجز سره العسكري وقد
اطلقت النيران على المسلحين الاربعه الذين
كانوا يستقلون مركبه مدنيه وقتلت احدهم
بداخل السياره وايضا اثنان من المسلحين
استشهدوا برصاص جيش الاحتلال عند
خارج السياره في ساحه قريبه من احدى
البنايات قيد الانشاء والمسلح الرابع قد
سلم نفسه حسب بيان جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بعد اشتباك المسلح مع القوات
الاسرائيليه قوات الاحتلال ايضا حصلت على
تسجيلات الكاميرات المراقبه المتوفره في
تلك المنطقه وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه اكدت
بان الشهداء الثلاثه هم جهاد وعدي الشامي
وهما ابناء عمومه وايضا محمد الدبيك اضافه
الى الاسير الذي تم اعتقاله وهو ابراهيم
عورتاني به من مصادر محليه داخل مدينه
نابلس وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه اكدت ان عدد
الشهداء الذين سقطوا برصاص جيش الاحتلال
منذ بدايه هذا العام وصل الى 84 شهيدا
بينهم خمسه عشر طفلا الفصائل الفلسطينيه
هي زفه ونعد الشهداء الثلاثه الذين سقطوا
برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هذا اليوم
واكدت بان هذه الجريمه هي تضاف الى مسلسل
الجرائم المستمره بحق الفلسطينيين سواء من
جيش الاحتلال او من المستوطنين واكدت انها
لن
تثنيهم عن مواصله النضال والكفاح ضد
الاحتلال وهذا ايضا ما جاء في بيان مجموعه
تعرير مجموعات عرين الاسود التي قالت
وانها مستمره في عمليات او مسلسل العمليات
الثار
للشهداء الفلسطينيين سواء من مقاتليها من
المقاومه الفلسطينيه او من المدنيين الذين
يسقطون جيش الاحتلال في هذه العمليات
العسكريه المتكرره بشكل شبه يومي في
المناطق الفلسطينيه
شكرا لك من نابلس مراسلنا سمير ابو شمل